so what is cryptography
cryptography is a field that deals with
securing communication and computation
we want to ensure both confidentiality
and integrity
today cryptography is used all over the
place the users often are don't even
know they're using cryptography your
cell phone uses it all the time anything
you do online has cryptography in it
in cryptography what motivates us is the
real world problems so what what do we
study whatever the world kind of throws
at us
my name is I'm a researcher at Microsoft
and an Adjunct professor at MIT
my research focuses on theoretical
cryptography in particular but more
largely I'm interested in theoretical
computer science
so people use cryptography for thousands
of years and they often just came up
with schemes and hope they were secure
and everything was secret about them one
key takeaway about modern cryptography
as opposed to like the classical
cryptography that was used thousands of
years ago is that today actually all our
algorithms are public the way I think of
it whereas cryptography used to be an
art now it became a science
when modern cryptography started the
emphasis was on securing communication
you know a message was sent you want to
make sure it's secret you want to make
sure it's not tampered with you want to
make sure it's authentic so our goal is
to kind of encrypt
this message so we nailed that part
that's that's working well now we're
dealing a lot with securing computation
there was a time where a smartphone
started to come out and later smart
watches came out all of a sudden we had
a lot of little devices that interact
with the real world and need to do
computations but they're very weak
devices so a natural way to think about
is okay they'll ask some the desktop or
some cloud computing or whatever a
stronger computational device to do the
work for it so now with the abundance of
weak devices delegating computations off
to a cloud computer there's two main
challenges that come about first maybe I
want privacy I don't want to let the
server know what I'm doing
another question which is kind of very
very dear to my heart and I spent a lot
of time working on it is exactly
ensuring the Integrity of the result how
do we ensure that the result we get is
actually correct
how can we do that in a verifiable way
so the computational heavy device that
generates this computation we want that
device not only to give the output also
to give kind of a succinct certificate
that certifies the correctness of this
output
in cryptography or in computer science
in general the way we think about proofs
really evolved there's work from the 80s
where the gold was to come up with
proofs that reveal no information beyond
the validity of the statement and the
first step to that is the definition of
what's called interactive proof
we have a user he's had like a little
smartphone and then we have like a
powerful server you can think of it to
the cloud you
know
this is your he's weak he's hot you want
the strong Cloud to do a computation for
you
so what interactive proofs gives us is
two things first it allows us to prove
things without giving out information
beyond the validity of the statement how
to do this with interaction here's what
message one he has question and so on so
forth so the power of interactive proofs
constant reflected these questions have
a randomized
but the other thing interactive proofs
give us is it gives us a way to prove a
statement in a very succinct way using
much less communication or much less
bits
so while interactive proofs are very
advantageous and that they allow to hide
information and they allow it for much
more 16 proofs their inherent
disadvantages the main disadvantage is
that an interactive proof is not
transferable
once you eliminate in traction there's
no real proof that you still have the
security guarantee that the interactive
protocol had let's say we only care
about the succinctness the fact that the
proof is short and can be efficiently
verified you really want to have a
certificate saying that this trip that
you know indeed this is a valid
transaction assuming you can't check it
on your own so how do we go from here to
our actual certificate what do we do we
apply what's called fear chamir Paradigm
or also known as Vietnam heuristic
you can take any interactive proof
in which the verifiers messages are just
random and convert them into
non-interactive ones so they can
essentially eliminate interactions using
cryptography what we get by applying
feature mirror is what's called a
succinct because it's short
non-interactive because we limit
interaction argument and the
the acronym for this is snug so seeing
non-attractive argument one main place
where snargs or in other words a
certificate that certifies the
correctness of the computation are used
a lot in the blockchain today ethereum
are using snargs as a way to certify the
validity of their transactions we're
trying to simulate this arbitrarily
complicated function G and fool just
exactly
so what are the biggest problems in
cryptography today
I had to think of the new biggest
problem one of them has to do with
quantum computers so cryptography is
based on computational assumptions the
security of our schemes are based on
some hardness assumptions we believe
that it's hard for example to factor
very very large numbers the assumptions
often no longer hold once we have large
scale quantum computers they could break
our assumptions and hence render our
schemes completely insecure however
contrary to the narrative about Doom I
actually feel a narrative of excitement
of oh let's see what a quantum computer
brings like what capability
we can upgrade most of our schemes to be
post Quantum secure we're still working
on it but you know we've made a very
large advancement on this front and
that's pretty exciting
[Music]